c'est une affaire qu'il y a un an
faisait grand bruit l'arrestation de
christian quesada candidats les 12 coups
de midi pour corruption de mineurs et
détention et diffusion d'imagés
pédopornographiques
une arrestation très médiatique qui
avait choqué de nombreux français et
donné lieu à de nombreux témoignages
face à ses preuves et à ses aveux
partiels christian quesada avait été
placé en détention provisoire le procès
s'est déroulé le 8 avril dernier dans
des conditions particulières puisque
l'audience a eu lieu par vidéoconférence
et le verdict est tombé
l'homme de 55 ans a été condamné à trois
ans de prison et cinq ans de suivi socio
judiciaire
il a été reconnu coupable de corruption
de mineur sur quatre jeunes filles mais
aussi d'avoir détenu et d'avoir diffusé
des images pédopornographiques
s'il n'a pour le moment pas décidé de
remettre en cause ce jugement christian
guessan a encore quelques jours pour
faire appel de cette décision ce soir en
exclusivité clair la candidate qui a
éliminé christian quesada nous livre son
témoignage
[Musique]
alors que l'art est avec nous mais
recycle r déjà je voudrais revenir sur
vous sur les nombreux jugements qui a eu
sur twitter nombreux internautes se sont
indignés trois ans de prison pour un
pédocriminels avérée comment voulez vous
dissuader ces pervers avec des peines
aussi légères
j'ai honte à notre justice trois ans de
prison pour christian quesada étant
donné qu'il a déjà fait un an
dans quelques mois elle pourra faire sa
demande pour sortir donc il est libre
les limites libre la justice de merde
comme d'habitude
seulement trois ans de prison pour
christian cazade a choqué écoeuré de
cette justice est clair est avec nous
regardent et claire qui avait été la
candidate quasi tron et qui se tend
quesada c'était une très grande surprise
pour tout le monde si tu es le 14
janvier 2017 regarde
heller 40 centièmes de seconde attention
crise thierry cain chanteur de rock
américain était l'époux de dita von
teese de 2005 à 2007
tiens un chanteur de rock américain
2005 à 2007 c'était barry levinson et
oui
c'est au caire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s
ça
[Applaudissements]
alors colère des internautes après la
peine requise de trois ans de prison
ferme pour christian quesada je vous le
dis énormément de gens qui se sont
plaints clair vous êtes celle qui avait
eu donc détrôné christian quesada vous
votre avis clair est-ce que vous pensez
pensé qu'il allait avoir plus une plus
grosse part est je pense qu'il est
arrivé juste parfaite je pense à ses
clients parce que les peines encourues
des spams assez important il faut savoir
que il a été enfin les deux chefs
d'accusation c'était corruption de
mineurs donc c'est l'article 207 ciré 22
du code pénal et celle prévue jusqu'à
sept ans de prison et l'autre était la
détention d'image pornographique c'est
l'article suivant 222-23 ses sept ans de
prison aussi donc pour les deux chefs
d'inculpation je pensais qu'il y aurait
eu beaucoup plus là trois ans c'est
quand même assez dérisoire sans compter
les pannes damon si je sais pas s'il a
eu des peines d'amendé des peines
d'amour à 75000 euros pour peu près les
deux chefs d'accusation que c'est très
très peu et je trouve ça un peu scandale
eut effectivement moi je suis mère de
famille et je suis un peu je suis
scandalisé vous êtes sûr je sais vous
êtes scandalisés claire passé passé vous
comprenez donc la colère de certains
internautes qui disent que ce n'est pas
une peine suffisante
c'est ce que disait également rené
malleville qui nous a rejoint après
j'aimerais voir la ville claire sur et
qu'elles nous disent qu'ils ont dit des
fans des 12 coups de midi sur cette
peine
rené tu vois les internautes sont
extrêmement énervé merci d'être là doc
tout cas rooney qui disent que trois ans
de prison ferme
c'est vraiment c'est inadmissible
journal comment j'étais outrée et j'aime
peu plus parce que comme je disais quand
tu dis oui à ces cas ça t'arrive à toi
quel péché que tu as des enfants des
petits-enfants et qu'elle saurait put
arriver et que j ai guy noël
extraordinaire il te vient une n 1 des
sculptures parce que moi
on peut excuser tout mais pas toucher
les enfants interdit de toucher n'a pas
les femmes les enfants les mets qui
s'attaquera aux femmes et aux enfants ce
sont des larmes ce soit des sous merdes
et mérite la justice j'ai cliqué alors
clair qui est avec nucléaire compenser
les fans des 12 coups de midi
de la peine de christian quesada de
trois ans de prison ferme qui est parce
que je sais que vous voilà vous
fréquentez beaucoup de fans et voilà des
12 coups de midi il ya une grosse
communauté
ils ont dit quoi de cette peine il ya
quelques groupes quand on parlait à
titre uniquement informatif composter
effectivement des articles en parlant et
voilà et il ya aussi la plupart des
groupes qui n'en parlent pas tout
simplement parce que je pense d'accord
le envie de parler de ce personnage et
et voilà et quelque part c'est pas plus
mal de ne pas parler lui mais en tout
cas il ya des groupes qui a eu les deux
réactions il ya des règles des gouttes
qui en ont parlé des fautes beaucoup
moins d'accord pour eux ils ont pour eux
ils ont plus envie d'en parler parce
qu'il s'agit d'émissions en fait comme
ils sont fans de l'émission c'est vrai
que pour eux ça reste un mauvais
souvenir question qu'est salah qui
restera mine de rien un des deux plus
grands champions de l'histoire de ce jeu
oui effectivement ça reste un des grands
champions de l'émission met d'ailleurs
je pense qu'eric est sur la bonne voie
pour parvenir à la déflation espèce de
toutes les normes et voilà il est très
bon et je souhaite vraiment de gagner de
le battre et puis d'autre part voilà je
ne suis pas sûr qu'un tel personnage
après avoir été mis à l'honneur mais
rythme on parle encore de lui et du coup
voilà je vous dis je suis vraiment
d'accord avec les des personnes sur
twitter j'ai fixé la peine est très
faible maintenant justice est faite
c'était aussi l'occasion de passer un
peu à autre chose ou en tout cas
ouais si la peine est chez le mathieu
voulait rage depuis tout à l'heure mais
oui parce que j'entends beaucoup de
choses mais il faudrait juste rappeler
que la justice se fait à à partir de la
raison et non à partir de l'émotion donc
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des enfants
évidemment c'est très triste qu'il faut
aussi dire n'importe quoi
il a quand même pris trois ans de prison
ferme il faut rappeler que c'est pour
possession d'imagés pédo pornographiques
et corruption de mineurs et les gens en
train de faire un amalgame un amalgame
honteux quand j'ai un violeur il n'est
jamais passé à l'acte c'est déjà énorme
en france d'avoir donné trois ans de
prison ferme pour quelqu'un qui entre
guillemets aurait pu passer à l'acte
pour l'instant de la pastèque alors je
rappelle qu il faut pas feria justice
toi même et deux pas sur l'émotion
leclerq a pas l'air d'accord avec vous
mathieu non alors effectivement elle est
la justice se fait avec raison et je
pense qu'effectivement le tribunal a
rendu son avis certainement avec eux les
faits devant soi maintenant il faut g
clap implique la détention d'image
pornographique elle des enfants derrière
donc c'est pas lui qui a commis les
actes on est d'accord mais à d autres
rencontres subi des actes de killian
d'ailleurs ses enfants et donc moi par
rapport à 16 ans je suis en colère
effectivement de ce qui se passe
je pense que trois ans est traité alors
juste claire j'aimerais vous poser une
question est ce que vous pensez que
christian quesada il va donc sortir à
priori dans deux ans c'est ce que nous
et nos même beaucoup moins on pensait
pour maintenant avec le jeu des remises
de peine je pense que comme il a déjà
fait un an que provisoire là avec le jeu
des remises de peine dans six mois un an
il est dehors alors est-ce que vous
qu'un bien est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va vouloir revenir sur le devant de la
scène
moi je pense honnêtement c'est quelqu'un
qui aime tellement la lumière que je
pense qu'il a il serait très mal c'est
sûr mais je pense que quand il va sortir
la vouloir raconter sa version des
choses
à tort ou à raison mais je pense qu'il y
a tellement besoin de ce cette lumière
qui va revenir sur le devant de la scène
d'une manière ou d'une très bien merci
d'avoir été avec moncler mersault n'y a
pas moins de six habiles excusez moi je
peux juste vous demander quelque chose
les mêmes chiffres que vous voulez être
de vous et elle aimerait bien vous faire
un petit coucou si ça me dérange avec
plaisir avec plaisir claire vraiment et
je suis et je vous envoie des je vous
envoie des chocolats de pâques a comme
s'ils savaient comment comment elle
s'appelle comment il s'appelle salut ma
chérie et ma wii cmne à ma petite fille
était magnifique ma chérie je te fais
des normes bisous et je t'envoie plein
de chocolat d'accord vous aurez si merci
nous divertir tous les jours eh ben vous
êtes un amour et j'espère que vous
reviendrez nous voir sur le plateau très
vite et je vous inviterai avec votre
fille je vous fais de gros bisous merci
merci d'avoir été là et vous êtes
magnifique toutes les deux merci
beaucoup
allez merci déchiré garder le moral à ça
ça me fait plaisir ça ça me fait
vraiment ça ça me fait plaisir je vous
dit